I actually believe one of the biggest
reasons the world is anxious is we've
gone away from accountability we blame
everybody on Earth but ourselves if you
really look at the data that I look at
people spend the majority of their life
blaming their parents or the government
the [__] are you going to do with that
you're going to sit and dwell yourself
into death right where you start taking
on accountability you're like well I
could do this I could it doesn't mean
that it's not true doesn't mean that the
government doesn't make missteps doesn't
mean that your parents didn't make
missteps the question is what do you do
about it to me accountability has been
lost over the last two generations well
if I make accountable Aunt really cool
and there's a kids book like maybe that
inputs something positive if you can get
to affecting people at a younger age you
can actually have a humongous impact